running safety drills packing a go bag
making a plan it is all part of
preparing for any emergency september is
emergency preparedness month and clark
county is helping you get prepared with
a public service campaign candice
charles is live this morning from the
government center downtown with a look
at a drill that you could run with your
family so you're all protected up
candace i think there's a is there a
fire going on behind you what's going on
yes sorta and i got my shoes on now guys
heather i'm prepared good morning folks
the safety house demo drill is ran at
schools throughout the county and you
know what if they can handle it i think
that we can too i'm joined by fire
inspector nick gioletto who's going to
take me through the drill first tell me
how does this work this is our fire
safety house and for emergency
preparedness we like to teach the little
ones two exits out of your house and we
like to teach them if you see smoke stay
low all right let's do it okay so what
are we supposed to do
where the air is a little bit cleaner
okay
if you come up to a door feel it with
the back of your hand look for heat if
there's no heat keep going to your other
uh predisposed location okay and
hopefully your family members are
outside waiting for you and look at that
to the exit and look our family and
friends are outside waiting for us this
is all you need to do to make it through
a drill just like this thank you so much
i appreciate it and they'll be here at
the clark county government center all
week for preparedness month giving out
info so you can come on down here to
check it out for yourself for now live
from the clark county government center
off of north maryland parkway i'm kansas
charles 8 news now good job and i got to
give props to armando your photographer
too because i'm guessing he was walking
backwards
well he was prepared he wasn't he went
he did a good job didn't he
thanks guys